how do you connect a gamepad to react if
you want to control a game or a
presentation from a controller like this
that's what we're gonna learn today
follow me
[Music]
okay so what i've done so far is that
i've done a create react app and
then installed this
library called react gamepads just using
npm install so let's first
remove the contents of
the app here we can remove the logo
and now let's
import
use
game
pads and now let's call our hook
use
gamepads
so this takes a callback function where
we receive the gamepads and now we need
to store the incoming gamepad somewhere
so we will
import the use datehook
gamepads
set gamepads
[Music]
use state and we will start with an
an empty array
so in here we can
set gamepads let's just to not confuse
ourselves
we will
name it underscore gamepads in here
let's get some nicer colors
polar
white
main knight 100 viewport height
there we go it's a bit nicer to look at
okay so now i'm going to take my gamepad
and plug it in
one good idea is to go to gamepad
tester.com
and you will see it will say no gamepad
detected but as soon as i press a button
it will detect an xbox 360 controller
and we can make sure that our controller
actually works properly in the browser
so let's start consoling things here
so
we get a lot of logs here
so we can see that it's an object and it
has a property of zero and there we have
a gamepad object
so maybe we first convert
this object to an array
so instead of setting
gamepads like this we do
object
dot values
so now if we console
log
gamepads from our state
now we have an array of gamepads instead
let's first make a check for the state
if game
if not gamepad
return
we can return
just a string
game pencil
length
and then let's make a mapping over the
game pads
gamepad
id is
gp dot
id
okay
so our loop is working
so we also have buttons on our gamepad
so let's create another loop
of
gamepad dot
buttons dot map
okay so we see that our gamepad button
is also an object
so we can
use the value
so now we have the index and the value
so now we can see that as i start
to press these buttons
they get the value
so for the buttons they get zero and one
for the trigger buttons in the back we
get a value between zero and one as i
press them down
the gamepad also has axis so let's
do the same for the axis
so now we've got four more
so let's console log a stick to see what
we have
steak
so we have axis
and on the axis we get the value of the
axis immediately so we don't have to do
value here
okay so now we got zeros and as i start
to move the sticks around we get the
values of the sticks so i can see the
top ones are for the left stick
and the first one is for x and y left to
right and the second one is for up and
down
so the third one is for left and right
on the right stick and the fourth one is
up and down on the right stick
so now let's create some nicer labels
for these so that we don't just use the
index
okay so i went through
the buttons
and they came in this order
and the access
came in this order so now instead of
just doing the index
we can do
there we go and let's do the same for
the axis
there we go so now it becomes a lot
easier to see
a little experiment to see if we can
effect some styling
by the gamepad inputs
okay so i added a style prop to the
app
div
so here i made an experiment to change
the red value so this
axis value will go from
minus one to 1
so i already have 128 so
this whole
parenthesis can be
a minimum of minus 128 and maximum of
plus 128 so that creates a range for
this red value between 0 and 255
or 256.
so the full range that i can affect with
my
my stick now will be from 0 to 255 so
the the whole
range of values for the red color
so i will save it and let's
try it out okay so the background
changed color so now
the when i don't touch the controller
this value is zero so we have 128 128
128
so let's inspect that
so now if i pull the stick to the left i
can go down all the way to to zero for
the red value
and if i go to the right it goes all the
way up to
almost the full range
i can reach 250 at least
so i can really quickly
adjust the background of the site using
the left stick here now
so i will post this on github so you can
try it out and use your imagination to
see what what
parts of your app you want to control
using the gamepad
if you
ever do like a presentation slide deck
in react
then you could connect a gamepad to
control the slides i think there are
lots of
cool stuff
especially if you're creating a gaming
react like some of the tutorials that i
have on youtube
it would be really neat to implement a
gamepad as the controller instead of the
keyboard
but thank you so much for watching i
hope you learned a lot please
if you enjoyed the video
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel
and i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
you